what are you teaching your children what
are we teaching our children of the
planet what relation do we have to this
air well relation do we have to this
water to this food to our planet into
our Sun are these just objects that we
pillage for resources and then sell in
an economy or are these sacred and
divine things how do we teach our
children do we even collectively
recognize that the same water that we
are drinking now is the same water that
dinosaurs drank that that same water
cycle has been happening for billions of
years the same water that makes up 70%
of your body the same water that you
drink for hydration that you shower with
the clean is all part of that
hydrological cycle on this planet do we
teach children that do children truly
embody that knowledge that wisdom deep
within their core we are here on the
unceded territory of the Musqueam a
First Nations people of Canada in
British Columbia here in Vancouver and
this is all super sacred to them and
it's becoming more and more clear that
Canada is focused on teaching their
children about the First Nations and
they're trying to do their best to heal
what has been a series of hundreds of
years of trauma for their First Nations
people here we are at the beautiful
University of British Columbia at their
Museum of Anthropology where they house
also
many of the First Nations artefacts here
and they have a co-creative relationship
a harmonious relationship with many of
the First Nations indigenous tribes that
then help teach young children about the
truth of their history we in the United
States and around the world can do
better at teaching our children about
the truth of indigeneity and the truth
about colonialism and the truth about
the traumas that it has caused and
further progress the healing that needs
to happen in order for us to all be
whole and for us to all consciously
evolve together what are we teaching our
children think about it think very
carefully about what we are teaching our
children think very carefully about how
it can be more about interconnectedness
interdependence
on each other in nature and knots
feelings of separation think very
vigilantly about how it can be about
augmenting the existing educational
fabric to teach more about the First
Nations around the world and what
colonialism did and how we can heal that
trauma how we can integrate best
together moving forward this is
paramount Canada is doing this well they
are healing well and the United States
can learn a thing or two imagine if
California did this
imagine if the East Coast did this
imagine all around the world we did a
better job at truly teaching our
children about First Nations people
and about the history of what has
happened and how to best integrate
moving forward how to best heal this is
a great learning lesson and I'm very
grateful to be here
thanks everyone for tuning in and
remember what are we teaching our
children ask yourselves ask each other
and make this a first principle point of
this reality we find ourselves in